- It's the first of the month.
You know what that means:
Rent's due.
- [Offscreen voice 1:] Oh, my God! [Laughing]
- [Offscreen voice 2:] Oh, wow.
- [Offscreen voice 3:] Thank you.
I'm so grateful.
- [Offscreen voice 2:] Thank you so much.
What's up, guys?
I'm Tyrann Mathieu, also
known as The Landlord.
They call me The Landlord
cuz I own the field, and I take care of
Chiefs kingdom. But right now my social
responsibility goes much beyond that.
A lot of people have been
impacted by COVID-19, especially
in my hometown of New Orleans.
I'm hoping to find a few families
that I can really impact
and help and love and support.
I'm looking forward to checking them out.
- My name is Averi Matthews, and
I'm the program coordinator
at the YAYA Arts Center. One of our young
artists, Quishan Reine, and his family,
are an amazing part of our community.
Quishan has been diagnosed
with autism in 2017.
And he has since served as a
voice for kids with autism.
His family has taken on the role as
advocates for youth with autism. His
family volunteers for everything.
This is an amazing family.
And any help you could offer them would
definitely mean the world to them.
Thank you so much, Tyrann.
[Phone ringing]
- Hey, how you doing?
- [Quiana:] Pretty good. How are you?
- Can you all hear me good?
- [Quiana:] Yes, we can.
- How's everything going?
- [Quiana:] All right.
- [Quishan:] We're doing good.
- Taking it easy?
- [Family:] Yeah.
- Where is Quishan?
- Oh, I'm right here in the middle.
- How you doing, man?
- Oh, I'm doing fine.
How are you doing?
- Man, I heard a lot of good things about you.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, man. I heard, I heard you can draw.
I heard you come from a good family, man.
I heard your spirit is good.
I heard you kind of like me—you
like to inspire other people.
So I try to, I try to
do the same thing, man.
- OK.
That's me.
- I could imagine y'all, you
guys have been through a lot,
um, you know, since this pandemic.
I heard you guys lost a few family members.
- We, first, April 21st, we
lost the kid's grandmother.
- I'm sorry for that.
- Um, thank you. A few days later, we
lost an aunt, and I guess maybe a few
days after that, we lost another aunt.
So, within the matter of a week,
we lost three family members.
- I'm so sorry that you, that you, that you,
that you all have had to deal with this.
I truly am. I, I know I can't be with the
family, but you, but you guys are not alone.
I just want to ask you guys,
how is everything going
financially? Like, how are you guys,
how are you guys holding up?
- It was, it was pretty difficult.
You know, it was pretty difficult.
My husband, he works two jobs.
So, you know, things were kind of
rough for a moment, but thankfully
he's gone back to work and we're
kind of seeing a bit of normalcy now.
- Well, I'm hoping you guys can, can
really continue to lean on each other
and push each other and encourage each other
because, you know, you guys are family.
And a lot of times that's all we have.
Um, but you know my nickname
is The Landlord, right?
- [Laughing]
- I run the field. I take
care of the kingdom.
Uh, you know, I heard your story,
and I just had to reach out.
So, I wanted to show some love, but
I want you to check your texts right now, please.
- Oh, my texts? OK.
Oh! He's gonna—they gonna paying
two months of rent, y'all.
Oh, my goodness. That's awesome.
Thank you so much.
- Check your account after we hang up,
and it should be in there for you.
- That is so awesome. My God. Thank you so much.
- It was a pleasure.
- Thank you. And we wanted to also tell you
happy belated birthday.
- Thank you.
- And—
- Congratulations.
And congratulations on your Super Bowl win as well.
- Thank you so much. I appreciate that.
- And, also too, one small bit:
My cousins actually played little league
football with your brother Tyrone.
- Ah, that's crazy.
- Yes.
- You know New Orleans is a small place.
- It is. It is.
- Quishan, keep it up, man.
Keep that smile on your face.
- [Quishan:] Mmhmm.
- Keep being who you are. People
love who you are, man, so.
And it was good to meet you.
- [Quishan:] Thank you.
- It was good to meet everybody.
- [Quiana:] Thank you so much.
- [Family:] Thank you.
[Everybody saying goodbye]
- [Quishan:] Thank you very much.
- [Offscreen:] When's football coming back?
- [Quiana:] We can't wait to see you on the field.
- Appreciate it. I can't wait to get back out there.
- [Quiana:] I know. Have a good one.
- [Tyrann:] You too.